do not put anything out into the world
that does not
represent your absolute best come to
learn to come to be a better version of
yourself
too many people start off trying to
prove that they are worthy of being
there
trying to prove that they should be in
charge
fun actually makes us smarter research
shows that it
improves our memory our concentration
and our ability to actually be creative
and get things done want to be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how you can
transform your world with a few simple
habits
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one produce master work with robin
sharma
a lot of creative people suffer from
over productivity
i'm going to repeat that again because
it's so important a lot of creative
people
suffer from over productivity they've
fallen into the snare
of believing they need to put out 50
books every year and
10 000 pieces of content every month
it's better to produce one master work
than a thousand mediocrities
and so oad is all about doing one or two
mona lisas over the course of your
career
maybe five but you simply
sweat the details oad obsessive
attention to detail do not put anything
out into the world that does not
represent your absolute best habit
number two
experiment with simon sinek look at the
end of the day
um when you're young and junior in your
career
it's the most confusing exciting
wonderful awful day of your life
right because now it's you it's
it's it's life it's life's journey right
you work your way up to eighth grade and
you have to start again at ninth grade
you work your way up to
senior and you have to start again as a
freshman you work way up and you're
great and then now you're you're
you're nothing again um
but i think uh there are too many
people who graduate school thinking that
they have to have it all figured out on
day one
yes and you don't because there's
something wonderful about being junior
inside a company
right you probably
don't have as many um responsibilities
as other people you may or may not have
a spouse
you probably don't have kids the vast
majority of people don't have kids at
this time in other words
you can do anything you can go try stuff
out also
your cost of living is a lot lower and
um and you can't really break anything
at a company and bring the company down
this is the best like if you're a senior
and you make a bad decision
you can break the whole company when
you're junior you make a bad decision
and
maybe you'll lose a little bit of money
right um
there's not much you can really do
that'll that'll break the company but
and so this is an amazing opportunity to
practice and learn and practice and
learn
find a mentor and a mentor is not
someone who is your champion who will
put in a good word for you so you get
the promotion right a mentor somebody
who's probably not even
at your company and if they are at your
company they don't have to be in your
chain of command
there's somebody who likes you and you
like them and they believe in you and
they see maybe a little bit of themself
in you and they want to see you do well
and they give you candid and honest
advice in other words come to learn to
come to be a better version of yourself
too many people start off trying to
prove that they are worthy of being
there
trying to prove that they should be in
charge and yet everybody knows
that you have no experience we know
we store your resume your resume says
your gpa
and what you graduate you have no jobs
right
you wrote it down here cafeteria
is not like the thing we're thinking we
took a bet on you because we liked you
and you're a nice kid
and you tried to form it but we don't
know you got no experience
right so this is the best time to try
things out and experiment
and push the boundaries and make sure
you're making friends and make sure
you're taking care of others and make
sure you find a mentor
and and and enjoy the journey um you
you if you take that route you're more
likely to be successful than not
i'll give you a personal example i
whenever i would interview when i was
junior
they would always say what are you
looking for and my answer was always the
same
a mentor i'd always say i know it's like
looking for love
but i'm looking for somebody who
hopefully will take me under their wing
and grow me
and i would turn down high profile
amazing jobs to take something that was
kind of rinky dinky
because i liked the person i would be
working for more and i remember working
with colleagues
who all they cared about was the high
profile job with the high paycheck
and they every decision they made was
paycheck which which one's going to pay
me more
i their lives i know what happened to
them because i've stayed in contact with
some of them
they're the unhappiest people i've ever
met they made a lot of money in the
short term
but then they ran out of passion and
they ran out of love and they ran out of
friends
and they their careers went like this
and plateaued and
it's because every decision they made
was money and i you talk about people
who have no joy in work
where the people who try to make the
decisions based on who i work for
and the kind of work they made less
money in the early days
i'm trying to do it with my hands they
made less money in the early days but
then it went like this later on right
to a t habit number three stay focused
with dan pena
follow one course until successful
most of the room would be infinitely
more successful
if they got became more laser beam
focused
because being a six figure hitta
isn't a big hit in the real world it's
not even a hitta
it's no money and i'm here to tell you
ways that you can be a seven-figure
hitter
eight-figure hitter and like myself a
nine-figure hitta
also if you wanna have more
self-confidence and self-belief check
out my 254 series where every day for
the next 254 days
i will send you an unlisted video the
sign says it takes up to 254 days
of consecutive action build a habit so
i'm going to be with you every step of
the way
if you want to be on for free 100 free
is a link below
go check it out i'll see you there one
of the real reasons we don't do the
things that frighten
us is because we are afraid of being
judged
and to become fearless why not find some
time every day
to practice becoming fearless and so
stop resisting i encourage you stop
resisting the natural flow of epic
performance
stop resisting the natural seasons of
life
habit number four don't give away your
power with joe dispenza
we sign up to become victims of our own
life
uh explain what that means and how do we
start shifting that away and what the
alternative is
i think there's degrees of understanding
this jay because
people use the word victims so much and
i don't really think
we spend a lot of time really unraveling
the idea
but if i said to you jay how are you
doing today and you said well
i'm really upset because of this person
or this circumstance or this condition
in my life then what we're saying this
is not conscious
this is an unconscious program what
we're saying is somebody out there
is actually controlling the way i'm
feeling
in the way that i'm thinking so if
something out there is controlling your
feelings and your thoughts
your victim to whoever whatever that is
now
here's the challenge the challenge is
when things go really well then you are
feeling really good
but when things aren't going very well
then you're feeling pretty bad
so then the end result of that is that
many people then become
unconsciously reliant on something out
there
to change how they feel and hear but if
they
don't understand that they're creating
reality all the time
and they're living in lack in
unworthiness in separation
for their whole entire life waiting for
the event to happen
to take away their lack or emptiness
well they'll spend their whole entire
life
wishing wanting waiting hoping and
so then that creates further separation
from things
changing so then the idea then is to
turn that battleship around
is it possible then that the way you
think
and the way you feel can begin to
produce
effects in your outer world now that
isn't
something that you swallow in one bite
it's a process
of gaining knowledge it's a process of
practice
it's a process of experience but once
you start seeing those synchronicities
those coincidences those opportunities
that start to fall into place because
you're experiencing change in your outer
world
if you're doing the work you're going to
start paying attention to what you're
doing inside of you
that's producing the effect outside of
you and once you correlate the changes
what of what you're doing inside of you
with the effect you produce outside of
you
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to do it again
and all of a sudden
you're going to start believing more
that you're the creator of your life
and less of the victim of your life so
if your thoughts and feelings some have
somehow have an effect on your outer
world
and you're reacting to the same people
at the same place at the same time in
the same circumstances
then you're actually reaffirming the
same reality because you're thinking
equal to everything that you know
so that in order to change that we have
to begin to
be greater than our environment and a
being
is how we think and feel so when people
begin to practice this
they're not so quick to
give their power away to the person or
condition in their life because
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some problem or condition in your life
the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause well
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy so you're giving
your life force
you're giving your energy away to that
person or problem that you could be
using
to heal that you could be using to
create a new future
so then teaching people then how to
self-regulate
and find the present moment and settle
their body down from those unconscious
programs or those emotions that they're
conditioned to
that's the work and so then when you
start
lowering the volume to those emotions
and you're doing the work and
mastering yourself in some way as you
begin to change your emotional state
you're not going to be thinking about
that person or problem and you're going
to begin to take your power back and
it literally begins to build a person's
own
electromagnetic field now they have
energy to heal they have energy to
create a new future
habit number five respect the game with
gary vee
i like micro failure i like micro
failure
i hate macro failure like death of your
business
is bad but but
to me you know what's funny i'll use a
boxing analogy my favorite boxing
i watch a lot of boxing i think boxing's
a very interesting
and i know and i'm super into mixed
martial arts but i grew up on boxing i
understand it better
and i like watching it because there's
so many things that happen in boxing
first of all what i love about boxing is
there's nowhere to hide
you know like it's super interesting
right
there's nowhere to hide number two
there's some there's a scenario boxing
that i love the most
there's for some reason there's nothing
more interesting to me than watching
somebody get knocked down in the first
round
and then go on to win the fight easily
it's an interesting psyche
right and i like that and this is what
i'm thinking about it which is like
here's what's bad in boxing and in
business going into a fight
getting knocked out in the first round
and losing the match
bad getting knocked down and then having
the adversity to readjust to what you
got caught on
and navigating it to easily win a fight
is remarkable
that's how i think about
entrepreneurship people
the reason so many people struggle with
entrepreneurship is
you have micro failures almost daily
and they're very in your face you can't
hide
and uh i like that uh i like failure i
because i think i deserve it i hate when
people don't respect the game
when i fail it means i [ __ ] up
and i like that habit number six do you
with david goggins
who i was i was this nobody guy and i
created this goggins
and that goggins there's david goggins
and there's goggins
david goggins is a calm cool guy that
sits back
used to be uh you know weak kid
now he's just a normal guy goggins is a
guy that is willing to tape up his legs
to go after it
um in that book you read about david
goggins and also goggins
what i realized in my life is that
goggins is who i love
goggins is who i created my dad
created david goggins i created
goggins so what's happening with me
and since can't hurt me came out and
since i got on social media which is why
i
don't like social media which i'm not on
there very much which i give people
one time i have to do me
i have to do me so people get it twisted
man
i am who i am yeah what's in that book
is me yeah so now what they see is this
guy who's trying to get people to get
off their
ass and that just happened to happen man
i didn't set out when i set out to be a
seal and set out to go to ranger school
and all this stuff
i did and break records i didn't set out
to please
right i didn't set out to say hey pay me
now
i got a great story that
and i realized now that my life has kind
of gotten to a point where people know
me
i have followers and whatnot the biggest
depression of my life
is you get caught up into helping so
many people out
and it's great and i love that but you
lose yourself in all of that
truth it literally and people go man but
but my god like you're changing
i get all that [ __ ] man but what the f
is motivating you in that book
what's motivating you is the stories i'm
telling you about what i did in my life
once i stopped living that i'm no more
yes i am not the [ __ ] that you
are now being motivated from
so right now in the mirror i now got
back to goggins
i'm now back to running 100 miles a week
i'm now back to getting the
i saw and i talked to my girl about all
the time
you you you travel you speak you you
know you
all this it's all great and dandy for
some for most people
i'm goggins what makes me me is the
dungeon
and yeah and people well oh my god
they're gonna hear this my god dude
you don't have any peace in your life
don't get it twisted weak people
who hear me get off poopy pants about
how i talk
so be it what changed me
was i had to be hard on myself yep
and i have to continue to grind
myself into a fine dust yeah
period that's where i feel good i've
accomplished something
if things come easy it's not fun i must
fail at something repeatedly it has to
haunt me
and then once i complete it i i
accomplished something
i don't want to set out and say oh
there's an a
we're good right stupid no i want to
turn it in a million times and say you
failed
you failed and i said okay roger that
and sit there and analyze
what i'm doing wrong go to these places
that people don't go to anymore because
all this
social media everything's computerized
i want to go to that dark place my mind
is okay how are we gonna get this done
and habit number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is have more fun with marie forleo
before we get to
how to have more fun in 2021 let's talk
about
why it is so important you know there's
actually a growing body of research
around fun and there's
so much that we gain when we're more
silly
and playful and have more fun in our
lives so first of all fun
actually makes us smarter research shows
that it improves our memory
our concentration and our ability to
actually be creative and get things done
number two when you're having fun you
tend to be a lot
less stressed and you guys know this
right when you're stressed you're kind
of cranky and miserable
plus stress depresses the immune system
which is not
good given the situation we're in right
now so having more fun really makes you
healthier and stronger most important
though leona and i think you know this
intuitively you mentioned it in your
question about how this might be one of
your biggest regrets if you don't get it
handled
funny enough one of our dear friends
bronnie ware who's been on the show she
wrote that
incredible book the top five regrets of
the dying right
so she learned in her research that
actually
one of the biggest regrets that people
have
when they're about to take their last
breath is this
i wish i let myself be happier in other
words i list i wish i let myself be
sillier
and have more fun and just enjoy life
more
fun is an inside job it is always within
your control
it's really a choice that you have to
make every single day
let me tell you about how i learned this
so when i was young
my dad owned his own small business and
like most small business owners i know
many of you are in the audience right
now
you know that sometimes you have really
intense deadlines right you've got to do
this incredible amount of
work in this short little period and it
can be
stressful so there were times when i was
growing up
that my dad had to go to the office and
there was a huge job he needed to get
done
for my mom myself and my brother rather
than staying home and going like oh we
wish we could see dad
what we would do is actually all go to
the shop he ran
a printing company and we would actually
have
work parties we would do this sometimes
on weeknights mostly on weekends and
here's what that looked like
so my parents actually turned these work
weekends into
full-fledged work parties we had a big
boombox you got to remember this was the
80s
my parents would get us pizzas and
throughout the whole weekend
while we were doing real work we would
take these dance breaks and
party breaks where they would play such
fun music
we would dance around the shop we'd have
a slice of pizza we'd laugh
and then we go back to getting things
done so i was
trained by the nature of who my parents
are and they're amazing god bless them
they're still alive and they're still
so much fun and um i wish i had a video
i could show you guys
my dad dancing in the aisles of grocery
store
anyway they really taught me the fact
that you could bring
the party to anything that you do and
i've adopted that for my own life so i
want to pass that along to you
when you're thinking about how to have
more fun in 2021 first you know it's an
inside job
it is always within your control and it
is a choice that you can make
number two you got to decide if you're
going to bring the party
what elements are important to you so
for me
there is something i always bring music
right this is my ue boom i take it
almost
everywhere i also do silly things like i
have a reggae air horn
some of you may have heard that before
some of you may be wildly annoyed by it
i don't care but music dancing
movement sometimes a reggae air horn
those are elements of my party
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you get motivated
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
following through
that's not enough but when you write
down what time what place
and how you're going to actually take
action on it you jump to 91
chance of following through and when you
have public accountability and you
commit
to other people that you're going to do
it it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you you have to learn to tie your
self-worth
to the process not the results this is
this is a real mind twister but if you
can figure this out you can
adopt this mindset shift it will change
how you see the entire world
and also get you more results successful
people
are you results oriented sure do you
want to get a result yes do you want to
hit the revenue goal of course do you
want to get that award yes
fantastic but it's not the point the
most successful people in the world
i've studied enough of them they love
the process
of doing the work they love the actual
work
it's not work for them as opposed to
just the results of the work
here's why it's so important if you tie
your self-worth
your identity your sense of self to
getting results
you're only going to do the projects
that you think you're going to get a
result on
you're not going to show up every day
and fail and fail and fail and fail and
fail if they don't fail
because you tie yourself to getting
results so you're going to pick the
projects where you know you're going to
get a result
ergo i like that i like that word
you play small for life you play small
for life because you're only taking on
the projects where you know you're going
to get a result
you're racing against three year olds
because you know you're gonna win
but you're never actually happy where if
you chase
the effort if you tie yourself worth
your self love your self belief
to the effort did you show up today did
you do your best you try your hardest
there's gonna be a lot of days where you
don't get a result
but you're gonna end up accomplishing
way way way way more
than you ever thought possible because
you're taking on new challenges that you
never thought you could do
i see this trait over and over and over
and over and over again and we hear it
in the words of
follow your passion or follow your bliss
or do what you love
and it's definitely tied to it but the
identity piece is what's so important
you become the person who loves doing
the work
who takes pride in the work and that
happens to get a result the result is
secondary the result is what comes
as a result of doing the work that you
love doing
i look at making videos for example i
i don't watch most of these videos back
when i'm watching them back it's to
it's to see how i can do better how can
i learn what did i mess up what
you know did i did i dropped the phone
that i stumbled did i
is the microphone you know not working
properly like where can i get better
i like the idea of doing the videos i
like the idea of creating content that
is gonna touch somebody's life
maybe this video reaches a million
people or maybe it reaches eight but in
those eight there's somebody where it's
gonna
this video is the one that'll make a
difference for them that's my sincere
hope
every time i press record i turn out
another video
and there's been over 10 000 videos not
all of them public but
last week i checked on the main channel
10 600
uh something videos on the channel how
how how do you make that many videos how
do you keep going
how many years later are we in this how
do you just keep because i love the
process guys
i love the process i like making the
videos
it's not just about the result and so
you know you know a version of this
you've you felt the feeling of
just hitting a goal how many times if
you had a goal
and you hit the goal you hit it hey i
hit the goal
and you celebrate and it's a milestone
moment and you did it
but then what happens the next day how
long is it how long is euphoria of
hitting that goal last for you
a week a day
like what happens the next day you're
back to hating your life
waiting for the next goal that you're
going to hit
you have to learn to switch it to say no
the the goal matters is great it's not
that goals don't matter
but it's secondary to the process that
you're enjoying
do you like actually doing the work can
you can you pat yourself on the back if
you can't reward yourself for the effort
you're putting in
there's a there's very likely a serious
lack of self-love in your life
i have something that i call the pillow
test which is which i think is very
valuable at night before you go to bed
you're going to put your head on a
pillow right
before you put your head on that pillow
ask yourself am i
proud sincerely of the effort that i put
in today
and if it's a yes then congratulations
you passed a pillow test
and it's no that's the path down into
lack of self-love lack of self-belief
lack of self-confidence like no i'm not
i'm not proud of how i showed up
other people might think i did a great
job other people might
say how fantastic you are other people
uh might be happy at looking at your
instagram when you're showing off all of
your accomplishments
right but you're not proud of you that's
the biggest thing that's the biggest
game that's the game we're all playing
are you proud of you
when you look yourself in the air at
night are you
proud of you for what you put in today
if you want to learn the seven ways to
become more productive check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i've been doing this for a long
time now i'd say beat that thing up that
monster out there
that warms this planet that nourishes
and gives us light i can see again